.
♪♪
>> Greg: HAPPY MONDAY.
HAPPY MONDAY, EVERYBODY.
HOPE YOU HAD A GOOD WEEKEND.
CALM DOWN LADY.
WELL, IT'S A STORY THAT ROCKED
THE GLOBE LIKE A GIANT ROCK
HITTING A GLOBE.
OR, IN THIS CASE, TWO GLOBES.
AND, AS USUAL, WE'RE THE ONLY
SHOW THAT'S COVERING THIS.
YES, IT'S DAY 18 OF THE IT
HAPPENS UP THERE WE REPORT DOWN
HERE.
YOU'RE WATCHING GAZOOMBA GATE,
DAN 2023, WEEK THREE.
>> Greg: YEP, IT'S WEEK THREE.
AS YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN ON TOP
OF THIS STORY LIKE BIDEN'S NOSE
ON A GIRL SCOUT'S FRESHLY
SHAMPOOED SCALP.
IT'S THE STORY OF THE SHOP CLASS
TEACHER WHO'S WEARING SUPER
JUMBO NEVER EXISTED IN REALITY
PROSTHETIC BREASTS TO CLASS.
IT'S GREAT.
IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT OF A WATER
EMERGENCY LANDING, YOUR SHOP
TEACHER CAN BE USED AS A
FLOTATION DEVICE.
BUT THE STORY ISN'T SO MUCH
ABOUT THE MONSTROUS MELONS BUT
THE SCHOOL'S REACTION.
THEY'RE STILL ATTEMPTING TO
NORMALIZE THE SITUATION THAT IS
ANYTHING BUT NORMAL.
HERE'S A RECAP.
ACCORDING TO THE TORONTO SUN,
SHE, WAS ONCE A HE, BEGAN
IDENTIFYING AS FEMALE LAST YEAR
AND STARTED WEARING MASSIVE
PROSTHETIC BREASTS TO CLASS.
BUT APPARENTLY ONLY RECENTLY
KIDS IN THE SCHOOL STARTED
POSTING ABOUT HER.
THE SCHOOL IS STANDING BY HER
SAYING, OF COURSE, WHAT'S REALLY
AT ISSUE IS HER GENDER RIGHTS.
IS IT ALL ALONG TROLL OR WAS IT
A MISTAKE CONVERTING BRA SIZE
FROM INCHES TO METRIC.
ONE THING FOR SURE IF THERE'S A
SHOP CLASS THAT REQUIRES
PROTECTIVE GOGGLES, THIS IS IT.
NOW THERE HAVE BEEN ANGRY
PROTESTS, UPSET PARENTS AND
AROUSED AND CONFUSED BABIES.
AND, OF COURSE, THE USUAL WOKE
SCHOOL BOARD THAT WILL DEFEND
ANYTHING IF IT FITS THEIR
TWISTED VIEW OF THE WORLD,
INCLUDING THOSE TWO MOTHER OF
ALL COCONUTS UNDER HIS OR HER
SWEATER.
BUT WHAT'S MISSING IS THE
TEACHER'S WORDS.
ACCORDING TO THE TORONTO SUN, A
PAPER, KAT, THE TEACHER STILL
SHOWS UP TO CLASS EVERY DAY.
YET, I CAN'T FIND A SINGLE
INTERVIEW WITH THIS PERSON.
MAYBE IT'S TOO DIFFICULT TO GET
THE MIC WITHIN REACHING DISTANCE
OF HER FACE.
BUT IT'S MORE EVIDENCE TO ME
THAT THIS MIGHT BE ONE BIG CHAIN
YANKER.
THE SCHOOL AND THE BOARD,
THOUGH, ARE STILL STICKING WITH
MINDLESS BLAUTHER THAT THEY
SUPPORT GENDER RIGHTS EVEN IF
THEY LOOK AS FOOLISH AS A WOMAN
DOING PUSH-UPS
>> A SEXIST WOULD SAY!
>> Greg: JUST MAKING SURE.
BUT IT'S LIKE THE OLD FABLE THE
EMPEROR WITH NO CLOTHES EXCEPT
HERE IT IS A SHOP TEACHER WITH
CHEST CONSIST SO BIG IF THEY
WERE STATES THEY WOULD BE WORTH
98 ELECTORAL VOTES.
THE SCHOOL'S GAME PLAN IS TO
HOPE THIS SCANDAL SIMPLY
DEFLATES AND SOON WE'LL ALL MOVE
ON TO SOMETHING ELSE, BUT I'M
NOT.
AS A CHILD, I WAS BOTTLE FED SO
I'M EXTRA INTRIGUED ABOUT THIS.
STORY'S TOO BIG, TOO ROBUST, TOO
AMPLE AND ROW LEAPT WITH US TO
IGNORE.
I JUST WANT TO BURY MY FACE IN
IT.
I'M GOING TO MILK IT FOR ALL
IT'S WORTH.
YEAH.
FACT IS, OBVIOUSLY A PERSON CAN
DO WHATEVER THEY WANT WITH THEIR
APPEARANCE.
EVEN IF IT FRIGHTENS SMALL
CHILDREN.
EVEN IF IT CONFUSES BARBERS.
BUT STILL YOU'VE GOT TO FACTOR
IN TIME AND PLACE AND AGE
APPROPRIATENESS.
WE PUT GUARDRAILS ON EVERYTHING.
SURE, DRESS LIKE A MACY'S PARADE
FLOAT, BUT ON YOUR OWN TIME.
NOT AT SCHOOL WHERE THERE'S
KIDS.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH
THIS, THEN WHY CAN'T ANOTHER
TEACHER SHOW UP WITH A GIANT
INFLATABLE PENIS?
AND I DON'T MEAN BRIAN KILMEADE.
BUT THAT'S TRUE, HE'S NOT
INFLATABLE.
BUT HOW IS THAT ALSO NOT AN
EXERCISE IN GENDER RIGHTS?
IT'S THE SAME THING.
SO I RETURN TO THE ESSENTIAL
QUESTION.
IS THIS REAL OR NOT?
HERE'S ANOTHER RECAP.
>> AN ANONYMOUS POST FROM A
MESSAGE BOARD, WHICH IS WHERE I
GET ALL MY FACTS, CLAIMS THIS
PERSON ISN'T TRANSITIONING BUT
TROLLING.
IT READS IN PART, THIS DUDE IS
GAMING THE SYSTEM.
THIS TEACHER WAS ALMOST FIRED
FOR TOXIC MASS CUE LINITY LAST
YEAR AS WELL AS NOT EMBRACING
WOKE CULTURE.
HE DROPPED RED PILLS TO HIS
CLASS SUCH AS HOW SILLY GENDER
NEUTRAL BATHROOMS ARE.
THE SCHOOL BOARD HATES HIM NOW
HE'S UPPING THE ANTI TO EXPOSE
THE CLOWN WORD THE SCHOOL
CREATED.
WHO KNOWS THE TEACHER COULD BE
PUNKING EVERYONE.
IF SO, I WANT THIS TEACHER TO BE
MY BEST FRIEND.
MAYBE, MAYBE MY NEXT PRESIDENT.
ONE THING'S FOR SURE, WHATEVER
TICKET YOU THROW HIM OR HER ON,
IT'S GOING TO TIP OVER.
BUT PRANKS LIKE THIS EXPOSES THE
PROFOUND USELESSNESS OF THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
THIS GAG IS A MORE ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT THAN A STANDARDIZED
TEST.
FACT IS THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
RATHER JUDGE PEOPLE WHO HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THE TEACHER THAN
ACTUALLY MANAGE THE TEACHER
HERSELF.
IF YOU'RE CONCERNED, WELL, THEN
YOU MUST BE THE PROBLEM.
AND THE SCHOOL IMPLIES THAT BY
CREATING A SAFETY PLAN FOR THE
TEACHER.
WHICH SHOULD START BY INSTALLING
A SAFETY GUARD ON THAT TABLE
SAW.
HONESTLY, I CAN HARDLY WATCH THE
DELI GUY SLICE MY TURKEY BREAST.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SEE IS
THIS IDIOT ACCIDENTALLY SLICING
OFF HIS ACRYLIC AEROELAS.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE SUN E-MAILS
WERE SENT TO PARENTS TELLING
THEM POLICE WILL MAKE SURE
STUDENTS WILL BEHAVIOR WHEN THEY
PROTEST.
YES THEY MIGHT RIOT OVER BIG
FAKE BLEEP BLEACH.
WHAT DO WE WANT?
REAL [BLEEP].
WHEN DO WE WANT THEM?
NOW.
HEY, HEY, HO, HO, YOUR FAKE
BOOBS HAVE GOT TO GO.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY DOING THAT.
IT'S SURREAL THE STORY KEEPS
GOING ON REFLECTING THE SAD FACT
COMMON SENSE CAN NO MORE DIFFUSE
SITUATIONS.
A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CAN'T
DEFINE A WOMAN.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD SHOW HER A
PICTURE OF THE SHOP TEACHER.
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
EDUCATORS CAN'T EVEN ADMIT WHEN
THEY'RE BEING PLAYED BY AN
IMPRACTICAL JOKER 0 A MENTALLY
ILL MALE WITH A DISTORTED VIEW
OF WHAT A WOMAN IS.
RATHER THAN DEAL WITH THE
UNDERLYING TRUTH THEY JUST
COWARDLY MURMUR RESPECT THEIR
RIGHTS.
THEY COULD JUST ASK THE TEACHER
TO KNOCK IT OFF BUT UNLIKE THE
TEACHER THEY HAVE NO BALLS.
LASTLY, WHERE ARE ALL THE
FEMINISTS?
THEY CAN'T ALL BE TRIMMING THEIR
MUSTACHES AT THE SAME TIME.
>> WOW, YET ANOTHER SEXIST WOULD
SAY.
>> Greg: I'M GLAD YOU CAUGHT
THAT ONE.
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN FIRED IF YOU
DIDN'T.
SO HOW SHOULD A PROGRESSIVE WOKE
WOMAN TAKE THIS STORY?
IT'S NO COMPLIMENT THAT FOR A
MALE ADOPTING THE TRANS FEMALE
LIFE IT'S MORE ABOUT A COSTUME
THAT EXAGE RATES ONE OF THE MORE
SUPER OFFICIAL FEATURES OF
FENNEL ANONYMITY.
WHAT IF WHAT CONSTITUTES A
FEMALE IS SIMPLY GIANT FAKE
[BLEEP].
WE DON'T THINK MUCH OF WOMEN
THEN.
IT'S ALL JUST DRESS-UP.
IF I WERE A BIOLOGICAL WOMAN I
WOULD CALL IT STOLEN VALOR, BUT
REALLY IT'S LIKE STOLEN VAG.
BELIEVE ME, THAT'S GOING TO
STICK.
BUT THE GENDER WARRIORS NEVER
REALLY HAVE MUCH TO SAY ON THIS
STUFF.
THEY CLAIM TO BE FEMINISTS UNTIL
THEY FIND THEMSELVES UP AGAINST
MEN PRETENDING TO BE WOMEN.
THEY THEN SUDDENLY LACK
TESTOSTERONE.
IN THE END IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
THE TEACHER IS SINCERE OR SILLY,
IT'S THE RESPONSE THAT TELLS THE
STORY AND IT'S AS SAD AS IT IS
HILARIOUS.
AND YOU CAN BET THAT I'M GLAD I
GOT THAT OFF MY CHEST.
AND, YES, LADIES, IT'S REAL.
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS!
THIS PSYCHOLOGIST SPECIALIZES IN
DRIVING LEFT WHY I WAS CRAZY,
PROFESSOR AND HOST OF THE SAAD
TRUTH PODCAST GAD SAAD
>> SHE'S SO BUBBLY SHE'LL GIVE
YOU HICCUPS, OUTNUMBERED COHOST
EMILY COMPAGNO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HIS COMEDY SHOWS ARE
LIKE A LIQUOR CABINET, WOODEN
AND FULL OF BOOZE.
WRITER AND COMEDIAN JOE DeVITO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: AND FOR HALLOWEEN, SHE
PLANS ON GOING AS SOMEONE
PLEASANT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: GAD WELCOME TO THE SHOW
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS FOR MANY YEARS, WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS.
NOW YOU'RE FINALLY ALLOWED BACK
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Dr. Saad: INDEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVIEDING
THE PROFESSOR AND THEN RIBBING
ON CANADA.
>> Greg: COMMERCIALITY I WAS
GOING TO DO ALL SEGMENTS ON
CANADA BUT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
NEWS IN CANADA.
YOU HAVE ONE STORY.
AND THEN THAT'S IT.
AND THEN EVERYBODY GOES TO BED.
>> Dr. Saad: EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW, IN 2017, BOTH JORDAN
PEDERSON AND I APPEARED IN FRONT
OF THE SENATE TO PRECISELY WARN
AGAINST THESE KIND OF BOUNDARY
POSITIONS, THESE KIND OF EXTREME
SITUATIONS AND EVERYBODY LAUGHED
AT US, THEY SCOFFED, THEY MOCKED
BUT LOOK WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
>> Greg: WHAT IS YOUR GUT
FEELING ON THIS?
DO YOU THINK THIS IS -- IT CAN
ONLY BE TWO THINGS, IT'S A LONG
CON OR IT'S SOMEBODY WHO'S
MENTALLY ILL.
BECAUSE IF IT'S ACTUALLY TRANS
THEY WOULDN'T GO FOR THE GIANT
BOOBS.
>> Dr. Saad: MY FIRST REACTION
WAS THAT IT WAS REAL BUT NOW
THAT I'M HEARING THE GREATER
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SAYING IT COULD
BE A TROLL, THE REALITY IS
WHETHER IT'S REAL OR A TROLL IT
SHOWS THAT THEY'RE NOT DOING TOO
WELL THESE DAYS.
>> Greg: IT SHOULDN'T MATTER IF
IT'S TRUE OR FALSE BECAUSE THE
RESPONSE IS THE LAUGHABLE PART.
>> Dr. Saad: EXACTLY.
>> Greg: THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE -- INSTEAD EMILY THEY'RE
SO SCARED OF OFFENDING I GUESS A
SELECT GROUP OF TRANS MEN WITH
DDDDDDDDDD BREASTS.
>> Emily: WHAT I LOVE SO MUCH IS
WE CAN'T EVEN PUT THE FULL PHOTO
ON AIR.
WE HAVE TO BLUR OUT PART OF HER
PHOTO AND THAT HER MASK IS BELOW
HER NOSE.
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW
IT'S A TROLLY.
WHO SAID THAT THE OTHER DAY.
DREW SAID THE MASK IS BELOW THE
NOSE THAT'S A SIGN IT'S A TROLL
BECAUSE WOULDN'T SHE PUT IT
ABOVE HER NOSE?
I EXACTLY.
WE HAVE TO BLURT OUT ON AIR AND
YET THIS SCHOOL SYSTEM IS
SUBJECTING KIDS TO THAT.
COULD YOU IMAGINE?
I WOULD GIVE ANYTHING FOR EITHER
A TROLL OR A WOMAN WHO
IDENTIFIES AS A MALE JUST TO
ROLL UP WITH A HINDENBURG JUST
HUMONGOUS CUCUMBER EVERY DAY
SITTING IN FRONT OF THE KIDS AND
THEN HAVE CANADA BE LIKE, THAT'S
RIGHT, AND WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
POLICE PROTECTING THAT TEACHER
INSTEAD OF THE KIDS.
>> Greg: YEAH, I WONDER WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF A WOMAN DID COME
IN WITH A GIANT LIKE -- I THINK
THE SAFE WORD WOULD BE CUCUMBER,
BUT A GIANT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
WHY I WASN'T ALLOWED TO TEACH.
>> Emily: IRRITABLE.
>> Greg: BECAUSE I HAVE A
HUGE --
>> Kat: ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GOOD.
>> Greg: A HUGE LOVE FOR
CUCUMBERS.
I ENJOY A GOOD CUCUMBER.
IT'S COLD AND IT'S CRUNCHY.
>> Dr. Saad: DELICIOUS.
>> Greg: YOU CAN DO A CUCUMBER
SANDWICH WITH CREAM CHEESE.
>> Joe: IS THIS REALLY THE VENUE
FOR THIS.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE THIRD TIME
WE'RE DOING THE SHOW WE'RE DOING
IT EVERY WEEK UNTIL WE GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
NOBODY ELSE IS DOING THIS, NOT
DATE LINE OR 60 MINUTES NOT
OUTNUMBERED.
>> Joe: NO.
I'LL SAY THIS, IF THERE'S EVER A
LEGIT USE OF THE PRONOUNCE THEY
THEM, IT WOULD BE THIS.
OKAY.
SO THIS IS EITHER A TEEN-AGE
BOY'S WORST NIGHTMARE THINKING,
OH, HAVE YOU SEEN THE NEW SHOP
TEACHER HAS GIANT BOOBS.
THAT'S THE OLD SHOP TEACHER.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
HERE'S WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
OKAY.
IN CANADA IF YOU SEND FIVE BUCKS
TO A TRUCKER, THEY'VE GOT THAT
TRACKED YET WE STILL DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS REAL OR NOT.
WE'RE SEEING THE SAME PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS LIKE THIS IS BIG FOOT, A
COUPLE OF BLURRY PHOTOS, A
COUPLE OF BLASTER PRINTS.
SO IF IT'S NOT A TROLL, THIS
PERSON NEEDS TO SEE EITHER A
PSYCHOLOGIST OR A CHIROPRACTOR.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Joe: AND IF THIS IS WHAT THIS
PERSON THINKS A WOMAN IS, THAT
THIS COSTUME IS ABOUT AS
FEMINIST A WOMAN'S COSTUME AS
NORMAN BAITS WORE, A SHAME THAT
THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK A WOMAN IS
THIS CARTOONISH THING.
>> Greg: BUT HE WAS A SEXY LADY.
>> Dr. Saad: HE WOULDN'T HURT A
FLY.
>> Greg: WOULDN'T HURT A FLY.
INTERESTING POINT THAT THE
LITTLE GUY OVER THERE SAYS KAT.
WE SIT HERE AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS, WILL WE THEN BE
BLAMED FOR MAKING AN UNSAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS TEACHER
BECAUSE WE'RE CURIOUS WHEN IN
FACT THE UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT IS
THE PEOPLE ALLOWING MAYBE
SOMEBODY WITH A SERIOUS MENTAL
PROBLEM
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW, YOU MIGHT
BE.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS SO MUCH AND I
CAN'T BELIEVE IT BUT I ACTUALLY
HAVE HAD A NEW THOUGHT ON IT.
>> Greg: OH, GOOD
>> Kat: YEAH WHERE IT IS A TROLL
AND EVERYBODY SAYS IT'S SO
AWESOME.
IF IT'S A TROLL IT REALLY KIND
OF SUCKS FOR THIS TEACHER.
BECAUSE THE IDEA IS OKAY, I'M
NOT GOING TO GET FIRED SO I'M
GOING TO PUT THIS MASSIVE
[BLEEP] ON AND THEY'LL FIRE ME
AND I CAN GENDER DISCRIMINATION.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THE SCHOOL IS LIKE GOOD FOR YOU.
SO IT DIDN'T WORK.
SO THIS TEACHER EVERY DAY, IF
IT'S A TROLL, LOOKS AT THESE
GIANT [BLEEP] SAYS I CAN'T
BELIEVE I HAVE TO PUT THESE ON
AGAIN.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU'RE RIGHT.
THIS IS A GAME OF CHICKEN
>> Kat: I MEAN, HE MUST BE
EXHAUSTED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS?
THIS IS A GAME OF CHICKEN.
THE SCHOOL IS ACTUALLY TROLLING
THE TROLL
>> Kat: RIGHT.
IF IT'S A TROLL, THE SCHOOL IS
OUTTROLLING THE TROLL.
>> Greg: YES.
THIS IS AMAZING, IT'S LIKE A
COLD WAR AND YOU CAN TELL
BECAUSE THE NIPPLES ARE REALLY
HARD.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S THE GREAT THING ABOUT
BREASTS IS THERE'S SO MANY
DIRECTIONS YOU CAN GO WITH THE
WORDS.
>> AMAZING.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
YES, I'M GOING TO SHUT UP NOW
BUT WE'RE GOING TO